bueno
[Música]
ahora muy bienvenidos una vez más a la
entrevista de france 24 esta oportunidad
nos acompaña mobilia millán ella es su
jefe y activista mapuche fundadora del
movimiento de mujeres indígenas por el
buen vivir y también es la autora del
libro el tren de los videos moverá a
millán muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france24
de mal gusto saludarte moria bueno
preguntarle en primer lugar que
significa way efe
el west ham era la lucha auto de
felicidad de nuestro pueblo y el buen
defensor que salía justamente a
resguardar la vida de su pueblo y el
territorio y hoy tiene absoluta vigencia
en 6
usted moverá junto a muchas otras
mujeres indígenas ha plantado lucha a lo
que denominan el terry cidh yo cuéntenos
que es el terry cidh yo es un concepto
que sintetiza todas las formas de
asesinar la vida que tiene el sistema
dentro del tras recibió está contemplado
el ecocidio l fister incidió el
genocidio el feminicidio todas aquellas
maneras en que están realmente la vida
de nuestros pueblos y de la naturaleza
es arrebatada el que residió lo que
busca es ensamblar la relación
intrínseca que tiene el humano con todo
el resto de la naturaleza pero también
con su espiritualidad con su cultura con
sus espacios sagrados y es un concepto
que parte directamente de los pueblos
indígenas porque nosotros creemos que
hay lugares sagrados que hay espacios
territoriales donde habitan ponían
fuerza que deben ser respetada decir que
como hay un ecosistema tangible también
hay un ecosistema
perceptible y nuestra lucha contra el
territorio es lograr que este concepto
convierte en una categoría jurídica que
pueda juzgar y condenar tanto a los
gobiernos terribas como a las empresas
bueno su lucha por el territorio es
histórica y clave por supuesto pero es
muy interesante su visión sobre los
territorios hablan de cuerpos
territorios y voy a citar una frase de
eso ya en el mundo indígena el
territorio es lo que los determina y la
mapuches habitan un territorio y al
mismo tiempo este territorio las habita
verdad podría desarrollar esta idea tan
interesante
exactamente justamente tiene que ver con
nuestra filosofía con nuestra
cosmovisión nuestra espiritualidad hay
fuerzas que habitan en los ríos las
montañas la selva los lagos que esas
fuerzas también a veces se posan en las
personas y por eso es que tenemos por
ejemplo machito mujeres medicinas que
reciben esa fuerza esos espíritus de la
tierra en sus propias puertas y
transmutan después la energía por eso
nosotras hablamos que no puede haber
libre determinación de los pueblos si no
hay libre determinación de nuestras
cuerpos y de nuestros territorios
entonces por ejemplo si decimos la
fuerza del río el espíritu el río qué
a donde yo vaya esa fuerza de este río
me acompaña entonces a través de mí
también habla el río por eso es tan
importante la lucha por resguardar la
vida de los territorios hablando de los
cuerpos de las cuerdas no siente que los
movimientos feministas actuales de
alguna manera- ignoran quizás lo que
sucede con los cuerpos de las mujeres
indígenas hay sonoridad hacia las
mujeres mapuches muy gran hay bastante
desconocimiento de lo que acontece
dentro de los territorios en conflicto y
particularmente lo que nos está
sucediendo a nosotras mujeres indígenas
en este momento por ejemplo en argentina
está habiendo un creciente fenómeno es
terrible parte del ct recibió que es el
feminicidio indígena están matando a las
mujeres indígenas sobre todas aquellas
que luchamos por el resguardo de
nuestros territorios creo que esto se
conoce poco también la particularidad de
que argentina es muy racista es
eurocéntrica se cree la europa de
sudamérica y eso genera también muchas
dificultades para poder exponer esta
realidad
creo que el feminismo tiene que
plantarse desde un lugar no solamente
antipatriarcal sino anticolonial y
dejarse permear por esa visión milenaria
de las mujeres indígenas que traemos en
nuestra lista christie's y licitatorio
de nuestra tecnología ancestral entonces
creo que vamos a poder vencer a este
sistema de muerte abrazando la vida pero
recuperando la memoria de los
territorios de nuestras cuerpos
territorios y ese creo que es la misión
que el movimiento de mujeres indígenas
para competir tienen argentinas ahora
para muchísimas personas de américa
latina está atravesando una suerte de
proceso de revisión histórica y que está
impulsado por los pueblos indígenas
pueblos originarios del continente con
los recientes derribos de estatuas en
varios países hablamos de estatuas de
personajes colonialistas vinculados a la
esclavización no de que nos hablan estos
hechos
me parece que aparece hay una fuerza
telúrica del propio continente que nos
trae la memoria de la memoria de los
territorios que está intacta a pesar del
intento de exterminio de esa historia
donde los estados naciones invasoras de
los territorios indígenas levanta
levantaron otra narrativa que nada
tenían que ver con la verdad o esa
verdad están saliendo a la luz
a la luz nos muestra en los crímenes
cometidos por estos estados nación y la
justicia de los pueblos nos deja esperar
creo que des monumentalizar a estos
genocidas a estos criminales es una
forma no solamente interpelar la memoria
sino de interpelar al sistema y no puede
haber una lucha anticolonial si se sigue
entronizando y respetando las figuras de
los genocidas que llevar adelante
el asesinato de tantos pueblos no
entonces creo que lo que está pasando en
todo el continente
una
práctica de memoria verdad justicia que
los estados-nación no nos han permitido
el oficial y los pueblos no estamos
tomando en nuestras manos hablemos ahora
de lo que son las violencias hacia las
infancias indígenas las mujeres están
luchando contra algo que es aberrante
realmente cruel hablamos de la práctica
del cine o ahora podría contarnos de qué
se trata esto bueno también tiene que
ver con la continuidad de esas políticas
coloniales lamentablemente el cine o es
una aberración sexual cometida contra
las niñas indígenas que en los criollos
con cierto poder económico con cierto
poder político
violan a las niñas a veces emana a veces
de manera individual y ellos creen que
están viviendo como un rito iniciático
de la sexualidad de la nena pero que es
en realidad una experiencia traumática
que a veces deriva en suicidios que
deriva en muerte y que las
sobrevivientes de estas
aberración sexual el cine o hoy estamos
reclamando de manera categórica con
fuerza que el cine o sea realmente
condenado porque cuando las hermanas van
hacia los estamentos judiciales para
denunciar esto los jueces interpretan
que es una práctica cultural entonces
nosotros decimos no es una práctica
cultural es
realmente una práctica aberrante que
tiene que ser abolida de los territorios
esto sobre todo eso es un fenómeno que
sucede en el norte del país y por eso
estamos trabajando muchísimo una campaña
contra el cinismo
absolutamente aberrante movilidad bueno
ahí está está directamente ligado a lo
que es la violencia machista en las
comunidades indígenas gran parte de las
demandas sobre el territorio que usted
definió muy bien al comienzo de la
entrevista se articulan con violencia
machista sufridas al interior de las
propias comunidades referentes indígenas
varones continúan perpetrando la
violencia de género a través de
prácticas coloniales no como bien usted
decía cómo explica usted esta
reproducción de la violencia por parte
de quienes también han sido oprimidos
asesinados y siguen 2
creo que es justamente en la
colonización se ha inoculado dentro del
espíritu y el pensamiento de los hombres
y tal vez es el único privilegio con el
que cuentan porque en realidad son
oprimidos socialmente obtenidos
culturalmente los muchos mecanismos de
opresión también se alberguen sobre los
cuerpos y la vida de los hombres y el
único privilegio que les queda en ser
macho ser varón y lo utilizan contra sus
propias mujeres contra sus propias
hermanas sus madres sus hijas y por eso
estamos a explicándole a los hombres que
no podemos lograr la libre determinación
de nuestros pueblos si no hay libre
determinación de nuestros cuerpos
estamos digamos se desprende no de sus
palabras quizás la siguiente
interpretación el colonialismo sigue
existiendo pero bajo diferentes formas
definitivamente se ha logrado reciclar
la colonización se ha reciclado los
afectados republicanos coloniales se
reciclan y articulan modos más
sofisticados de opresión pero que
continúan optimizando el patriarcado
creemos a veces falsamente que producto
de la lucha emancipatoria de las mujeres
se están logrando de arriba pero en
realidad lamentablemente rápidamente el
sistema se vale de artilugios muy a
veces invisibles y sutiles para
reactivar esa violencia machista sobre
nuestras cuerpos ahora vamos a hablar
también de una demanda que ha sido
histórica por parte de los pueblos
originarios y que hoy en día está en la
agenda de todo el mundo de los medios de
activistas y que tiene que ver con la
lucha contra el cambio climático no como
los está afectando y cómo están viviendo
esta lucha en estos momentos en los que
la realidad está demostrando cuestiones
muy difíciles vinculadas al
calentamiento global por ejemplo
bueno la situación es realmente
alarmante creemos que estamos en una
situación de crisis humanitaria dentro
de los territorios indígenas
fundamentalmente quienes reciben de
manera directa
esas consecuencias del cambio climático
son las mujeres porque por ejemplo la
escasez de agua hace que una tarea tan
cotidiana y sencilla como lavar la ropa
se convierta en un peregrinaje muy
difícil donde las mujeres por ejemplo
envía guaraní en la zona de la provincia
misiones tienen que recorrer entre 3 a 4
kilómetros para llegar al arroyo donde
pueden lavar la ropa y retornar a sus
comunidades porque los las han corrido
hacia zonas zonas completamente
afectadas zonas que se han vuelto de una
irreversible sequía también tenemos la
situación de que hay muchas arroyos
contaminados
la situación también de las hermanas
y en el sur de la
los mapuches como también de wences que
están sufriendo una afectación tremenda
en los territorios por la crisis hídrica
no hay agua está dejando de llover las
nevadas son cada vez más escasas
entonces todo este tipo de
situaciones afectan la cotidianidad
porque la logística el desenvolvimiento
de lo doméstico dentro de la casa que el
dar de comer que en para buscar el agua
que en la calefacción a con la línea son
las mujeres entonces su tarea se
recrudece muy amigas ya hemos llegado al
final de esta entrevista muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
por favor gracias a usted además a
nuestra audiencia y le invitamos como
siempre a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]